[Musica]
salve buonasera a tutti dopo tutto
quello che abbiamo ascoltato vorremmo
tornare un po alle basi e vorremmo
chiedervi chi di voi si ricorda la
chimica che ha studiato a scuola
avete paura alzate le mani che se lo
ricorda dai ci sono tanti studenti
alzate 9 paura non ne sa né lo giuro è
ok ok via c'è qualcuno almeno che si
ricorda e vi ricordate che cosa studi la
chimica studia la materia
ovviamente è di chi cosa è composta la
materia di te altre volte anatomici in
generale si giusto late è composta di
atomi tutto ciò che c'è natura e l'acqua
che veniamo e l'aria che respiriamo
tutto il nostro corpo è composta da toy
gli atomi che legandosi tra di loro due
o più formano molecole la chimica quindi
studia le molecole studia le loro
proprietà e studia soprattutto le loro
reazioni
scusate se non siamo presentate bene io
sono mai e sono una chimica
anch'io sono io sono l'uno anch'io sono
chiaramente un chimico come appunto
detto il presentatore iniziato sono nato
qua e ho iniziato la mia carriera qui ma
poi io sono andato per più di dieci anni
scandinavi a fare ricerche prima di
ritornare qua a siena
io sono nata in andalusia in spagna
ovviamente l'avrete capito per il mio
accento sono venuta alla università di
siena a fare il mio dottorato e ora
lavoro come ricercatrice luca io siamo
chimici e lavoriamo con le molecole ma
quelle che lavoriamo noi sono molecole
molto molto particolare
certo perché noi lavoriamo con le
molecole che sono coinvolte nella
visione la visione è quindi perché
vogliamo vedere molecole che sono
coinvolte in reazioni fotochimiche sono
quelle che ci permettono di catturare la
luce e trasformarla in colori immagini e
chiaramente soprattutto emotivo
come l'emozione di vedere un posto nuovo
ricordi te con si è andata la prima
certo la prima volta scambi no perché io
quando sono venuta prima volta qui a
siena era colpita dalle emozioni anche
l'emozione di di la natura che potevamo
dire anche la toscana o in altri paese e
anche bene anima ricaviamo intorno a noi
ma mi puoi dire dove si può trovare
queste molecole allora queste molecole
che si chiamano rodopsina si trovano
nella retina dei nostri occhi
voi vedete noi vedete questi tutte le
nostre presente la nostra presentazione
tutte le presentazioni di oggi perché
sul fondo dell'occhio abbiamo la retina
questa membrana che cattura la luce la
trasforma in segnali nervosi e la manda
al nostro cervello
tutto questo avviene qua in questa
membrana che qui vediamo né un'immagine
al microscopio che contiene i coni e
bastoncelli all'interno dei bastoncelli
c'è il protagonista dei nostri studi va
rodopsina questa molecola quaggiù
come avevamo detto prima le nostre
molecole sono molto particolare e per
questo è il nostro dipartimento è stato
che ha valutato come un centro di
eccellenza proprio e poi vedremo perché
sono tanti importante queste rodopsina
ma puoi dare ancora un po di
informazione su che cosa è narrato psi
incerto
allora se vediamo la parte centrale
della rodopsina abbiamo questa molecola
che quando viene colpita da un fotone
quindi da una particella di luce che
arriva inizia una reazione molto
particolare chiamata foto iso merita
zione ovvero questa molecola chiamata re
finale inizia a cambiare la propria
struttura prima è leggermente ripiegata
poi comincia a distendersi ea diventare
più lineare questo può sembrare qualcuna
cosa di apparentemente semplice ma molto
potente ma per ora abbiamo un problema
questi molecole sono talmente piccole
che nemmeno le più potenti microscopi
elettronici può vedere e noi come
ricercatori per studiarli creiamo dei
modelli computazionale
e avere una migliore visione di dirlo
dop sini settimane ma ci può dire un
attimino meglio come funzionano questi
modelli certo cercherò di spiegarlo nel
modo più semplici immaginate di avere
questa fantastica macchina
già ma un qualcosa un pochino ma sta
bene per ora non se la possiamo
permettere però chissà
va bene allora noi è la macchina è il
cuore pulsante ci sono il sì libri e
pistoni che si facciamo il confronto
diretto con il retina e con la rodopsina
e il nostro retinal e poi c'è il vano
motore che come nel caso della rodopsina
e la cavità intorno aretina le e contro
nel funzionamento di là della rodopsina
e alla fine abbiamo la intera
carrozzeria che come la rodopsina selen
vairo nell'ambiente che introdurre si
apre di nahr e la cavità e la proteina
quindi praticamente noi utilizziamo
questi modelli computazionali sono vari
livelli di approssimazione ma creando
che creano un unico oggetto come qui
vediamo nei vari colori ci lavoriamo e
possiamo quindi utilizzarli per studiare
queste rodopsina ne sono molto
particolari
ovviamente tra le diverse funzioni che
si può trovare sulla sulla rodopsina c'è
la conversione della luce in segnale
nervoso mi possa anche in energia
chimica ma ovviamente essendo molecole
molto particolare noi abbiamo un motivo
per cui e studiamo certo non le vogliamo
soltanto vedere quale sia la loro
funzione le loro proprietà ma vogliamo
poi poterle utilizzare per suggerire
come nuovi strumenti ad esempio in
quella che viene chiamata la biologia
sintetica del concetto quello della
biologia sintetica ma qualcuno l'ha
sentito parlare prima è la prima volta
ci troviamo ha spiegato allora la
biologia sintetica è come i mattoncini
lego e vediamo qua
supponiamo di avere un mattoncino lego
particolare ovvero con dentro un re
finale
che lo rende quindi foto attivabile
sappiamo mattoncino speciale possiamo
costruire un robot fatto di leggo che
poi possiamo controllare con la luce e
quindi essere foto attivabile la
biologia sintetica fa la stessa cosa
prende tanti mattoncini da vari
organismi li mette insieme per creare
nuovi strumenti nuovi macchinari bio
molecolari che speriamo di poter da a
cui speriamo di poter dare dei motori
foto attivabili comunque a vendola idea
della biologia sintetica e anche dei
modelli al computer
noi possiamo studiare della rodopsina
che sono state mutate comunque
aminoacidi specifici sia quello
arancione sia quello e blu e anche di
studiare nuovi e artificiali e retinal
icone proprietà migliorate questo mi
questo o questo guardano parte quindi
come un sommario della biologia
sintetica possiamo dire che si può fare
del miglioramento tra la chimica
computazionale sì perché noi non siamo
soltanto chimici siamo dei chimici
computazionali quindi creiamo questi
modelli che vogliamo utilizzare per
migliorare la nostra salute è
chiaramente anche tutto l'ambiente
quindi non solo rodopsina e naturali ma
anche prodotti né modificate il problema
è che non tutte le rodopsina e
modificate sono buone alcune andranno
anche problemi e purtroppo ci portano
possono portare anche alla cecità
immaginate
di passeggiare ogni sera in piazza del
campo e giorno per giorno di vederla
sempre più buia anche se nessuno sta
cambiando l'intensità dell'illuminazione
di giorno passeggiate e cominciate a
vedere un alone nero sempre più intenso
che cosa sta succedendo andare
dall'oculista e vi diagnostica una
retinite pigmentosa
quanti di voi sanno che cos'è la
retinite pigmentosa qualcuno sì per
fortuna lo sanno comunque in pochi
perché una malattia rara della vista che
colpisce una persona ogni 4.000 è una
malattia per cui tutt'oggi esistono
soltanto delle cure palliative volte a
rallentare il cammino il percorso verso
la perdita della vista mentre melo
spagna è una malattia spesso legata a
delle mutazioni delle proteine di cui vi
hanno appena parlato marie luca le
rodopsina esistono tante altre malattie
della vista più comuni che hanno più
persone che sono legati alla mutazione
di queste proteine ma nel nostro
progetto di dipartimento abbiamo deciso
di lavorare sulla restituite pigmentosa
facendo una scelta che noi definiamo in
un certo senso coraggiosa perché oggi
nella valutazione della nostra attività
di ricerca siamo sottoposti dallas
comunità scientifica un metodo di
valutazione che è molto simile a quello
dei like dei social network per cui sarà
molto difficile diventare un famosissimo
influencers e ci occupiamo di una
malattia poco popolare però tuttavia noi
riteniamo che l'università abbia una
missione che è quella di occuparsi di
queste malattie perché per noi le
persone affette da una malattia rara non
sono santo persone rare ma sono persone
speciali come tutte
e altri e sicuramente non devono mai
essere lasciate sole con la propria
malattia
quindi c'è bisogno di dare loro una
speranza di cura e da qui la nostra
scelta di questa malattia come modello
da studiare nel nostro progetto
in particolar modo vogliamo provare a
trattare la retinite pigmentosa a
trovare delle soluzioni per il suo
trattamento usando l'optogenetica e
lotto farmacologia state tranquilli
anche la prima volta che ho letto queste
due parole mi sono abbastanza impaurita
però vediamo né un po più da vicino
optogenetica 8 farmacologia hanno in
comune la radice greca opto che indica
tutto ciò che ha a che vedere con la
visione la vista quindi la luce 8
farmacologia e diciamo quella parte che
studia lo sviluppo di farmaci attivati
dalla luce lotto genetica invece a
costituita da una serie di tecniche di
ingegneria genetica che permettono
attraverso la luce di attivare o
disattivare la trasmissione nervosa per
capire come utilizzarle della retinite
pigmentosa
facciamo un passo indietro e dobbiamo
ripensare un po più a livello molecolare
e generale ha come avviene il processo
della visione
abbiamo visto la rodopsina eretina le
loro agiscono insieme all'interno dei
bastoncelli come se fossero più o meno
un cancello automatico che noi durante
il giorno
teniamo aperto lasciando passare persone
e auto chiunque venga a trovarci ma che
la sera chiudiamo andando a premere un
telecomando che metterà una luce ad una
un'onda a una determinata frequenza che
andrà ad attivare un sensore che porterà
una serie di movimenti meccanici con la
conseguente chiusura del cancello
e blocco del traffico all'interno dei
bastoncelli il canale ionico è il nostro
cancello che normalmente lasciapassare
atomi carichi positivamente sodio e
potassio carichi positivamente e è
connesso in qualche modo ad un sistema
queste su iso dalla rodopsina e dal re
finale in cui il re finale il nostro
sensore che colpito dalla luce come
avete visto subisce delle modificazioni
iso merita così si dice normalmente in
termini chimici e porta una variazione
tridimensionale della proteina che
conduce alla chiusura dei canali ionici
questo si traduce in una segnale
elettrico che arriva il nostro cervello
e che il nostro cervello elabora nelle
immagini che noi vediamo fin qui tutto
spero più o meno chiaro vediamo che cosa
succede quando noi abbiamo delle
mutazioni nell'autopsia sostanzialmente
possiamo avere due problemi possiamo
avere il nostro sensore il cancello che
non dialogano più supponiamo che si sia
rotto un filo elettrico per cui il re
finale non riesce più a legarsi
propriamente la rodopsina nel suo sito
attivo perché sono cambiati gli
aminoacidi in questa zona
quindi come possiamo agire semplicemente
più o meno semplicemente andando a
progettare preparare e sintetizzare il
laboratorio una nuova molecola che sia
attivabile dalla luce come il re finale
ma che sia in grado di legarsi a questa
rodopsina musata quindi sostanzialmente
usiamo loft o farmacologia farmaci foz
attivabile un po più complesso è il caso
in cui la rodopsina ere finale si legano
riescono a dialogare ma se rotto un
perno del cancello per quel cancello non
riesce ad aprirsi e chiudersi
propriamente come noi vogliamo come
capite bene
non possiamo in questo caso pensare di
andare dentro al nostro occhio e
cambiare il perno del cancello perché
piuttosto difficile però ci viene in
questo caso in aiuto l'optogenetica che
sfrutta più o meno quello che in
agricoltura è il principio dell'innesto
così come noi andiamo ad innestare su un
ceppo divisa americana la vite europea
per evitare che prenda delle malattie a
cui sarebbe soggetta così noi andremo ad
innestare nelle nostre cellule che hanno
una rodopsina mutata non più foto
sensibile e funzionante delle nuove
rodopsina funzionanti come facciamo a
fare questo
intanto stabiliamo che caratteristiche
deve avere questa rodopsina
fotosensibile sulla base dei modelli che
vi hanno fatto vedere mari e luca
a questo punto dobbiamo trovare qualcuno
che investi questa rodopsina e noi
sfruttiamo un virus
sì esattamente come quello
dell'influenza del raffreddore con la
differenza che questa volta lo
sfrutteremo senza che ci faccia venire
alcuna malattia per innestare dentro il
nostro occhio un pezzettino di dna che
avremmo preparato il laboratorio che sia
in grado di produrre la rodopsina che
noi abbiamo stabilito di voler innestare
nell'occhio
inseriamo questo dna dentro al virus
iniziamo il tutto dentro al nostro
occhio e avremo da parte delle nostre
bastoncelli la produzione di una
rodopsina funzionante sfruttando come
metodo per inserire questo pezzetto di
dna dentro al nostro materiale genetico
quindi dentro al nostro dna
soltanto il meccanismo che normalmente
il virus usa per infettarsi questa volta
però anziché produrre altri virus
produrrà prodotti né funzionanti e se
queste rodopsina non saranno in grado
di interagire con i vecchi sensori
andremo di nuovo a preparare e
sintetizzare in laboratorio delle
molecole foto attive che siano in grado
di legarle di attivare il processo
visivo e quindi di consentirci di vedere
meglio quindi esattamente come in
agricoltura in cui serve tempo per
selezionare le specie da innestare le
une nelle altre e trovare le tecniche
migliori per fare questo innesto anche
il nostro cammino sarà piuttosto lungo
ma grazie a tante competenze diverse
diciamo che questo cammino ormai ha
iniziato il cammino volto a dare una
speranza di miglioramento della qualità
della vita a chi sta perdendo la vista
e badate bene noi non siamo medici
come vi abbiamo già detto siamo chimici
ma anche noi abbiamo un ruolo nel
migliorare la qualità della vita
probabilmente anche dell'ambiente in cui
viviamo
e allora proseguiamo questo nostro
viaggio che ha come protagonista la
rodopsina perché questa molecola oltre
ad essere coinvolta in una rara forma di
malattia della retina può essere usata
anche per migliorare la qualità
dell'energia che produciamo e quindi
dell'ambiente grazie alla sua
sensibilità alla luce infatti la
rodopsina può essere usata per produrre
energia come in un pannello fotovoltaico
ma perché è importante che ci si occupi
o sarebbe meglio dire ci si preoccupi di
energia
pensate per un attimo cosa succederebbe
adesso se non avessimo energia in questo
teatro
le luci si spegnerebbero completamente
il microfono non funzionerebbe più il
proiettore non si accenderebbe e i
nostri cellulari
una volta finita la carica della
batteria non si riaccenderebbero più
siamo circondati dalla tecnologia ma
senza energia tutti i nostri
dispositivi sarebbero degli inutili
pezzi di metallo
ma da dove proviene tutta questa energia
di cui abbiamo bisogno
circa l'ottanta per cento dell'energia
proviene dalla combustione di petrolio
carbone e gas naturale riguardo a queste
fonti sappiamo due cose la prima è che
si stanno per esaurire o diventerà molto
costoso reperirle
nell'arco di poche decine d'anni la
seconda è che bruciando le generiamo
così tanta anidride carbonica dove era
aumentato la temperatura della terra di
un grado un aumento di temperatura che
non ha precedenti nella storia del
pianeta
allora che fonti possiamo usare in
alternativa a queste per esempio le
fonti rinnovabili che sono rispettose
della natura della salute dell'uomo e
del pianeta e che per la loro capacità
di autorigenerarsi possono essere
considerate inesauribili fonti di
energia rinnovabile sono il vento le
biomasse la geotermia
ma soprattutto le onde del mare ma
soprattutto lui il nostro meraviglioso
sole il soleil inesauribile perché
dobbiamo considerare che brillerà per
altri 3 4 miliardi di anni
e inoltre pensate il sole invia sulla
terra in circa un'ora
una quantità d'energia che l'umanità
intera consuma in un anno e di tutta
questa quantità enorme di energia noi
usiamo pochissima quindi quello che
dobbiamo fare assolutamente e imparare
utilizzarla meglio sapete che nei
pannelli fotovoltaici l'energia del sole
è trasformata in corrente elettrica
ma ora noi li vediamo come delle brutte
macchie nere sulle nostre case o nei
campi
allora pensate se questi pannelli non li
potessimo fare colorati e flessibili
allora li potremmo utilizzare come
tegole dei nostri tetti oppure li
potremmo integrare
rivestiti o perché no nelle vele delle
imbarcazioni
ebbene alla base di questi dispositivi
fotovoltaici di nuova generazione
c'è una molecola foto attiva un
colorante che è capace di catturare
l'energia del sole e attraverso un
processo molto simile alla fotosintesi
clorofilliana di generare corrente
elettrica
e questi il colorante che ha funzionato
meglio in questo tipo di dispositivi o
un colorante a base di proteine un
metallo che si chiama rutenio ma che
disponibilità abbiamo di rutenio in
natura
per rispondere a questa domanda ci viene
in aiuto la tavola periodica degli
elementi che come ricorderete dagli
studi di chimica raccoglie tutti gli
elementi a conoscenza dell'uomo
questa è la sua veste tradizionale ok ma
il 2019 l'anno internazionale della
tavola periodica per cui per l'occasione
questa tavola periodica è stata
ridisegnata in una nuova veste questa
per aumentare è stata ridisegnata per
aumentare in tutti noi la consapevolezza
delle limitate risorse della nostra
terra del nostro pianeta
difatti il rutenio come potete vedere
occupa una casellina molto piccola
molto più piccola rispetto ad altri
elementi della tavola periodica e tra
l'altro di un colore allarmante
arancione questo sta a indicare che la
sua disponibilità futura è a rischio per
il crescente utilizzo quindi cosa
possiamo usare in questi dispositivi
in alternativa ai coloranti al rutenio
per esempio materiale di natura
biologica di cui abbiamo potenzialmente
una grossa disponibilità e allora ecco
che torniamo alla protagonista del
nostro racconto la rodopsina che
attraverso i modelli di cui vi hanno
parlato luca e mari stiamo studiando nei
nostri laboratori
questo perché
noi vogliamo rendere il più piccolo i
nostri studi più efficiente possibili
meccanismi con cui l'assorbimento della
luce da parte di una rodopsina batterica
possano portare alla produzione di
corrente elettrica e quindi di energia
come avrete capito da questo nostro
racconto stiamo nei nostri laboratori
affrontando una grande sfida
una grande sfida scientifica ma anche
una grande sfida a livello mondiale
siamo la generazione che sta toccando
con mano i cambiamenti climatici e che
può fare qualcosa di concreto per il
futuro come chimici ma soprattutto come
cittadini dobbiamo agire in maniera
responsabile e consapevole limitando e
rendendo più efficiente l'uso delle
risorse a nostra disposizione come greta
la ragazzina svedese che tutti i venerdì
in manifesta fuori dal parlamento
svedese per sensibilizzare i grandi su
questo tema
migliaia di giovani lo scorso venerdì 15
marzo hanno manifestato nelle piazze del
mondo e dimostrano di aver capito prima
e meglio di noi
l'importanza di questi temi e allora
dobbiamo impegnarci per lasciare in
eredità un futuro degno di essere un
mondo degno di essere vissuto perché
come dice un famoso proverbio non
abbiamo ereditato la terra dai nostri
antenati ma l'abbiamo presa in prestito
dai nostri figli
tanti ricercatori che con storie diverse
culture e competenze diverse lavorano
insieme per migliorare la qualità della
vita e dell'ambiente e grazie
[Applauso]